all right selena
welcome back hi so
the last time you did an interview with
me you uh the phone number i had for you
no longer worked
so i had no way to contact you so
through uh
it was one of your relatives your aunt
or somebody contacted me and told gave
me your number
yeah my biological family reached out to
me
and they had told me that you were
looking for me and that if i
wanted to be looked for
so they had hit you up and said that um
oh i hit him up i'll see if he gets back
to you with you all up and i know that
for a while i was looking
i just you were trying to find me yeah i
was driving around downtown
yeah because i lost my phone and yeah
yeah so we found each other finally
so what's been going on so our your last
talk was very interesting because
at the time you were probably of all the
girls i've interviewed probably one of
the most brainwashed
girls that i've talked to because you
were like thinking that
yeah i was thinking that everybody was
out to get me everybody's against me
and that i was the one that had to do
the brainwashing
so that i could get what i need to get
but you know it's like survival mode for
me
except for i was too into that survival
mode i was thinking that
you know just the worst you know
like brainwashed yeah the whole
lifestyle with drugs and doing this kind
of work and the hours that you're
keeping and the lack of sleep and all
that
no exactly and the drugs wasn't helping
it either because
coming off of them and just feeling the
withdrawals and just thinking like how i
could even be stuck in this
it just gave me like a refreshment in my
mind and
i don't know like on the fifth day going
cold turkey i was like
i don't know how to explain it but you
did it on your own
yeah like it feels good it feels like um
you feel strong like mentally stronger
and you feel more
like power like i don't know i feel like
not
somebody can play with my head now
because they know like i knew he knew
because he was giving me the drugs or he
knew that i was high
so he could tell me whatever to make me
shut up or tell me whatever to just be a
okay with it but you know
so now that you have a little bit of
clarity yeah how do you view
where you were at last time because you
were you're deep into it yeah i was
being willful
um i was mad and you know
that gateway drug was like trying to
make me contemplate on doing another
drug
that was way worse and way stronger and
i was like going through like a
depressed phase
i told you i was i had left him and you
know
i think at the time you didn't have a
pimp right no
and i was trying not to go back
especially during these withdrawals
right you were as ripe as anyone i've
ever
seen to be pimped out again and not only
that
i was desperate and feeling lonely
because i didn't have him or didn't have
a pimp
to even like lean on or look for support
because of these
like and you know with going through
withdrawals you're easily irritable and
like i don't know i felt like
i was getting ready to pass out any day
any time
i mean yeah i was thinking about it
because
you know they say checking ain't
cheating and looking at
cheating but it's like i'm not
desperate or in no need or want for one
like
i'm independent but getting getting
clean from the drugs probably gives you
a clearer mindset
oh yeah it does and it makes me feel
less of
a need and like a urge to like want to
be up under somebody
are you so have you been working are you
trying to get out are you what's your
plan um
i'm looking into working although i
don't want to because i already told you
what i wanted
but um you know just temporary
9-5 you know to keep me occupied and
busy in the meantime
while i'm waiting for my id and
everything to come in is
what's going to keep me like because if
i'm sitting in the house too long or if
i'm just sitting alone
i just start to like reminisce on things
and that's that's what got me
at the time when i was going through the
withdrawals like it's fast money
yeah you probably get somewhat addicted
to it right i mean
yeah i did i mean i still am
because i'm not gonna sit here act like
i don't
drive down fig or pass by thing every
once in a while
to like see if it's booming or if
there's you know
traffic but yeah
i don't know i'm trying to get into
another field like
like when i said last time there's
elevations to this it's like there's
that line of work and then there's a
higher class of that
yeah whether it's whether it's escorting
or only fans or something like that
yeah and to me only fans is something
that i've been thinking about heavy
so in the meantime i mean just you know
i'm not saying it's the answer but it
but
in terms of getting off the streets it's
better than the streets i mean for sure
because it's dangerous and
yeah and you can get killed out there in
the streets only fans no one's dying
yeah not only that even you're not even
meeting anybody
yeah you know or even have to shake
hands with the trick but
um especially like with these pimps now
i don't have to put or present myself
out there and let them think or feel
like they have access to touch me or
feel like they can try and
take my money because like i don't want
to say too much on how they get down
when you're independent or if you don't
have folks but
i'm just trying to be more of like the
how do you say it i don't know the word
for it but i'm trying to be more
classier what i do
yeah and now working the streets is
probably the bottom of the
yeah and i remember when we met you were
like
you don't even look like you should be
out here and that's when i was also like
see i know i'm not supposed to be out
here like this isn't i mean it's not to
say that this isn't me
because i've been doing it for so long
now it's not like i don't know what i'm
doing
or don't know how to do this line of
work
it's just like this support system and
helping getting
into a better field of this escorting
business because
it's a business i feel like it is you
get money from it and
it's what's projected out there from
like
everybody now except for they don't know
how to do it yeah what i've learned
from trying to help some of the girls
that work fig and
done that kind of work is it's difficult
for them to
they're scared of elevation they can't
make the adjustment
yeah into a square job because because a
couple of them got square jobs they got
they got
nine to five jobs that were great and oh
i'm so proud of you that's awesome
they can't stick with it yeah i think i
think
therapy is needed or something is needed
so they can
get comfortable with that life or maybe
they just get addicted to the fast money
or something but
yeah it's it's not an easy adjustment to
go from
that kind of work and the fast money to
a square job that's
paying every two weeks and yeah having
the same money
that's something that i thought about
because the first time i've worked
at the warehouse job for graveyard i
couldn't do it like my feet were killing
me
i was impatient like and then i already
wanted the money then when i'm doing all
this [ __ ] where's the money like
oh you got to wait for two weeks paying
you know you get your first check this
like you know because i was so used to
fast money and i'm so used to just
getting it right then and there and
leaving with at least almost a thousand
dollars
every day like at night and so
for me i would probably need therapy
to not have to think about the disgust
of
men and the certain situations that i've
been through while i was working fake
and you know sometimes you do get
triggered or sometimes people know it
but it's the question it'll
like i said bring up a certain memory or
a certain like
feeling in a situation that i was in on
fig
and so if i'm dealing with people that
are at a job
and somebody pisses me off or somebody
does something it's like i would need
that therapy to work on how to be less
angry and more you know because you know
when you're dealing with certain clients
out there on fake it's not like a nine
to five you gotta i have to carry pepper
spray i might have to suck a trick up or
slap somebody for disrespecting me and
my boundaries
and you know i would just need that
practice on
like so they would probably need that
practice and to live in that square life
because they're so
used and was probably raised in the
streets and raised into doing that
and then when they get given the
opportunity and the chance
and given a handout to do and choose a
different path in their life
for me at first i felt like this is a
trick
like somebody wants something with me
like what do they want everybody's out
there
it doesn't seem like it could really
work too good to be true to be true yeah
and so i've seen that happen they miss
out on their yeah they miss out on their
blessings
i've i've offered help to certain girls
and they just treat it like
i don't trust it yeah and at first i was
you know i missed the two times that we
were i was supposed to meet up iffy
about it because i was so
i was always being set up always being
put in situations and
you know predicaments that i didn't want
to be in but i was tricked into it
because
it sounded good or they sold me a dream
and so now i'm at the point where it's
like you can't manipulate me
and you can't give me or impress me with
the idea of living a lifestyle that i've
already
gotten a you know piece of and it's
like i don't know i would do something
better with my money than spend it on
like
just first thing designer and i don't
even have a house to wash my ass and to
lay my head
it's so nice to hear you speaking
sensibly
yeah because last time you were it was
heartbreaking to listen to your
the way you were speaking it almost
seemed like you were destined to go back
to the streets and
yeah the drugs were a lot of people were
trying to push me back to that because
they seen it and they see me they feel
like they already know me
they feel like they know what happens
behind closed doors like
what i said is just a piece or like it's
not it's
a life story yes but my life isn't over
you know
it's like i'm not dead or anything so i
still have
a destiny i still have a path that i'm
trying to take a journey to
be on and a lot of people are trying to
you're 20 years old right
yeah i'm about to be 21 in august yeah
so you're you're still very young and
you can
you can be legal my life is barely
starting
if i think about it like just getting
out of this like
you know i won't have to ask nobody no
grown-ass man either to go in there and
give me no you're such an intelligent
young lady and it'd be nice to see you
make some better
healthier decisions then yes because
i'm tired of letting what people think
or what they have their opinion on to
make it feel like that okay i gotta do
what they're saying because i gotta make
them happy
like i'm done people pleasing because
that [ __ ] just led me into a depression
and into the drugs and into all that
[ __ ] that
is making me feel like it's not me
like i smell weed i always smoked medium
before i got into the drugs so
that's probably something that i'm also
cutting down too i'm not smoking as much
weed as i used to because
i want to be focused like i want to be
all the way into
there know who's talking to me or trying
to manipulate me and have my eyes on
certain people now because people
are trying to use my video as
oh you're that girl that was on that
youtube video huh that walk fig
um do you need help or like dude like
you know trying to like sound like
as if i'm being desperate and it's like
you know giving me a hand
is good but i didn't tell nobody that or
share that with anybody to make them
feel sorry for me
or to make them feel like i don't know
what i want or what i'm doing like yeah
another thing i've learned help is nice
i appreciate it because
the help that was being offered to me in
a different way was
the way that i wasn't trying to accept
why because like i said i had to give
something more in return
and they wanted to count favors and with
me it's like help me because you want to
because you see potential in me
because you know that when i get up
there you're going to be with me like
that's how i am
like one of the most important lessons
i'm learning is someone who's helping
some of the
people that i interview is to admit to
to
to set you up with things like you know
a car
and an apartment and things like that
doesn't really lead to
the end result that i have planned which
is you're becoming self-sufficient what
i've learned is
if you do the work yourself and get
yourself into a situation where you're
stable and supporting yourself then you
build self-worth self self-esteem in
yourself and you feel like you deserve
that success
exactly you've earned it yeah it wasn't
me giving it to you i was just
you know yeah and even if you were it's
like what
are they doing to keep up with it
because if you get a car you're going to
need the money to take care of it yeah
there's maintenance
insurance everything exactly just like
with an apartment
you got bills to pay you got furniture
to pay for you got decorate like you
know i don't want to just sleep in an
apartment with just a couch and a
mattress on the floor
like me i like to you know i know it's
going to take money and take
you know determination and not being
lazy or thinking of what
or feeling what other people are going
to think of anyway i've gotten past that
to where like i don't give a [ __ ]
like did you relate to your old persona
is
your your name on the street was dream
yeah i got my dream
are you are you dreaming any longer or
are you [ __ ] i'm awake now
you know i got dreams but i also feel
like their goals
like their goals that i'm reaching to
make and that i'm gonna
complete and be successful in right
because i know what i want it's so nice
to hear you speaking this way
yeah because i was being like like i
said a little willful
and like something like a barrier was
like holding me back from letting people
help me because i was afraid of what
other people out there that are in the
game that want to be out there in the
streets
do you get a lot of people that come on
to you saying oh i'm going to help you
i'm going to save you i'm going to do
this on the other
they can't because they're not in a
position themselves to do it so
it's like you can't save me because
you're not
fully there either it's a lot of empty
promises yeah
and it's like i'd rather just you know
actually speak louder than words for me
and so if somebody's not really putting
the foot in
and putting forth the effort to showing
me that they give a [ __ ]
and that they're not just saying because
they want something in return then
oh yeah my energy my aura the way i
carry myself and how i treat you and
talk to you isn't going to be the way i
would treat a client that's
trying to you know lowball me or you
know
play me like i'm stupid or don't know
what i'm talking about but
it didn't help because i was on the
drugs too it's like
i put myself out there to be easily
manipulated or to you know
and letting people know that i was on
drugs made people
also think that they could yeah the
opportunist came out
exactly yeah you know and i said like
i know i think last time i said
something with like the way you carry
yourself is like the company you keep
you are the company you keep or
something like that
um it took me a while to like understand
that because the people i'm hanging
around
are drug addicts like
and it's like a need to want to save
them
but i'm worried about myself now because
you know seeing how my family is and
even watching the youtube video you
would think that okay i've done some
damage to my daughter and my little
sister or something
you know there's a saying that i've
always heard from
when i did wilderness it's like you
can't fix it you can only heal it
and it's like that's something that i
always think about because
i'm not more of like a fixer i'm more of
like a healer i want to be able to if i
burnt that bridge with you you can't
like accept me back all the way that's
fine i understand i see where you're
coming from but
and understanding you know you know
getting on good terms because where i'm
trying to get to it's like i know
karma's a thing
and i've been worried and my
self-conscious husband was eating me up
during my withdrawals because it's like
[ __ ] my karma's about to come i'm about
to like you know what am i scared of
when am i running from but it's like
i was the i don't like to say i'm the
victim but i was a victim in that
because now that i've gotten off these
drugs and i've been
able to say yes say no on to direct
things that
i've been the people i've been saying
with now like they think
that i'm just trying to sit there and be
in the house all day i'm depressed they
keep coming and asking me if i'm
depressed and no i'm not depressed like
it's stressful sitting on your ass when
you're so used to going out there every
single day
and coming in at a certain time only to
shower up and get back out there
you know it's like i don't know i just
feel like renewed i feel new
like i don't know how to explain it yeah
i can your energy is very different
you're you're speaking sense now whereas
last time it was like
it's like i can go in circles and talk
about the things that i've been through
and that make me sad but it's like
okay now what am i doing to get through
that you think
not seeing yourself as a victim i think
is a big part of it yeah
and that's exactly what i had to stop
playing that role as and seeing myself
as because
then people are gonna start treating me
like that
and looking at me like pray and you know
try to break my boundaries and [ __ ] and
then they would have to see a bad side
of me you know i'm been working on that
side of me because
i know that there's something bigger
than us there's something
higher than us and that's law and i'm
not trying to get into any type of
you know affiliation with the law
enforcement or police by
getting in trouble and going out there
and selling my ass and showing my ass
just to get in jail and lose that money
again like
it's not worth it and i don't know i'm
trying to be smarter
about it work smarter not harder good
for you
yeah all right well selena thank you so
much for coming back and
thank you for reaching out to me yeah no
it's nice to see you making some
some good progress yeah you're going in
the right direction i appreciate that
yeah i get nervous because everything
yeah thank you because i'm trying to
i'm gonna get watch it's gonna be a
movie
i'm gonna i'm gonna get somewhere and
the more you see me every single